i know i know it's not monday but
samsung just dropped a huge new
announcement
and i had to make sure to tell you guys
about it
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about samsung's
brand new
samsung watch 3 and comparing it to
apple's
apple watch series 5. now if you're new
to the channel
thank you so much for joining me i hope
you enjoy the content i create
usually on this channel we talk about
technology and architecture
all things encompass i've made a promise
to myself and to you guys
to put out one video every single week
every single monday
now just two weeks ago i ruptured my
achilles tendon
so i'm still in crutches going to be in
crutches for a long time and probably
not gonna be walking for about three or
so months
but i'm still trying my absolute best to
make these videos happen
to set up this studio today by myself
was a little bit of a challenge and i'm
completely exhausted
so i apologize if that comes through in
my tone of voice
i think considering this is my second
video this week with a ruptured achilles
tendon on crutches and in a cast
that definitely deserves a like to help
with this video's algorithm
and if you really really want to make
sure you smash that subscribe button too
anyway let's get on with today's video
so like i said the samsung watch 3 was
just announced and without putting a
huge spoiler on this video
but it's basically a samsung active 2
just
reshelled now let me go through that and
compare it against what
apple's old series 5 has to do with it
i say old because apple releases its new
smart watches about september
which is only a few months away so if
you're debating these two
and swaying towards the apple side
definitely hold off to see
if apple's new series 6 is coming out in
september
so let's compare these two side by side
the samsung watch
3 comes in a 41 millimeter and a 45
millimeter case
whilst the apple watch series 5 comes in
a 40 millimeter and a 44 millimeter it's
like samsung was just trying to one-up
apple on this one so they both come in
three
variations of different colors samsung
comes in mystic bronze
mystic silver and mystic black whilst
apple series 5 comes in gold
stainless steel and space grey they both
start at the 649 australian dollar price
tag
and they go all the way up to 1259
if you're looking at apple series 5 or
849
if you're looking at the lte version 44
millimeter
samsung watch 3. the only difference is
if you're watching this video on the 6th
of august 2020
you can go out and buy an apple watch
series 5 right now in any tech store
whereas you're going to have to wait
till the 19th of august for the samsung
watch 3 to ship here in australia
all right so let's talk about the specs
of these two from a specs point of view
there isn't really much that you need to
really be aware of
it's a smart watch now i don't
personally love them so my opinion here
is a little bit biased
they can't do an absurd amount of things
they can't store an absurd amount of
stuff
so at the end of the day you don't need
them to be the powerhouse
gaming machines that a desktop is or
something like the note 20 ultra is so
the samsung watch 3 has gorilla glass
base with an amoled display
whilst the series 5 has a sapphire
crystal oled display
the samsung weighs anywhere from 49.2
grams to 53.8
depending on the model and the apple
watch comes in at about 47.8 grams for
the low end
40 millimeter version battery wise we're
talking 247
to all the way up to 340 milliamps for
the samsung
with 296 milliamps for the apple watch
with one gigabyte of ram in each eight
gigabytes of storage
in the samsung watch three and up to 32
gigabytes in the apple watch
now they also have a bunch of different
sensors in them all of them are exactly
the same
in both of them the only thing that i
can find different
out of the samsung watch 3 and the apple
watch 5 is the apple watch 5 has an
inbuilt compass
now before we talk about the actual
design and aesthetics of these things
let's talk about the features
beyond the basics that you'd get in any
single smart watch
now i know that most smart watches can
do all the same things so that's why i
want to specifically focus
on what these two can do different or
better than anything else straight off
the bat both of these have
full detection if you're somebody who's
getting on in their age or somebody like
me that's pretty much
broken their leg and hopping around the
whole house all day every day
and you're a little bit worried about
falling or your loved ones are a little
bit
worried about you falling over and
nobody being home to assist
the fall detection is an inbuilt feature
that is
very very useful say you're in my
position
you fall down the stairs knock yourself
unconscious
there's absolutely nobody around now
before i continue
touch wood that doesn't happen because
that's a very likely possibility
so if you did fall down the stairs the
watch would automatically detect that
you've had a fall
and signal a notification on the watch
if
you don't respond to this notification
in time
it'll start calling your emergency
contacts this means
somebody will be notified of your fall
and somebody will come
to your assistance very very quickly i
can't stress how important that is
especially for people
with injuries or people getting on in
life both of these have heart rate
monitors in built that watch 3 does have
an ecg monitor
so it tracks the rhythmic beat of your
heart unfortunately
this isn't active in australia or in
america it is only active in south korea
for the time being
but they are pushing the pattern to get
through it would again be a very useful
feature
for people with heart problems something
the samsung watch is starting to push
now is the cross collaboration between
the phone and the watch so they're
unique they are one
at the same time so for example if you
get a message on your phone
you take a look at it on your watch you
can automatically send a quick reply and
it tries
to use an algorithm to understand what
somebody has said so you can quickly
reply to them
it also has the added ability of when
you're using spotify
if you've started playing a song on your
phone you've found the playlist that you
want
you're jumping into a workout you only
have your watch on the phone in your bag
you can quickly tap through the songs on
the watch and see exactly what they are
all the features on both of these
devices are kind of aimed more to your
active lifestyle
to people who want to understand and
track their
their progress if it's running swimming
jumping gym
absolutely anything that's physically
demanding and requires
some sort of sensors to be able to track
this data
it is definitely targeted to that
community unfortunately the reality of
it is
if you just track all this data what do
you do with it
it's all well and good knowing that you
got six hours of sleep last night
or that you ran four kilometers
yesterday
but how does that help you
i think if you're training for a
marathon or if you're training for
a swimming contest or anything like that
and you want to progress further faster
keep track of it keep a log of it yes it
may have some potential
yes it may have some sort of useful
features
but at the end of the day in my personal
opinion
the smartwatch market is still not there
yet
it is simply an additional display off
the side of your phone
that can show you messages sometimes
talk to people depending which one you
get
and kind of awkwardly navigate through
apps okay finally let's talk about the
aesthetics of the device
if you know nothing about me well i'm a
masters of architecture graduate
and i'm an entrepreneur by trade i've
started multiple businesses and one of
them
being a watch company so i have sold
thousands of watches across the world
the plaque up there actually
symbolizes the first 10 watches i ever
created it's probably
a little bit out of frame yep it's
definitely out of frame
but i do know a little bit about watch
designing
so there's a few things on the samsung
watch that i think
could have been better and there's a few
things on the apple series 5
that i could think can be better for the
series 6. now the fact that i know a
little bit about what i'm talking about
when it comes to watch design
i think definitely deserves another like
and subscribe so let's take a look at
the samsung watch 3 first
so i wish the stitches match the actual
black leather
on the black model because it just kind
of stands out a little bit like a sore
thumb it's going for a very luxury feel
but it's not really portraying that it's
somewhere in between luxury and sport at
the moment
also the red bezel on the side doesn't
really fine tune anything it doesn't
really work with any other face but the
one that they've displayed so i find
that
a little bit weird from the back side
again still the stitching really really
bugs me i wish it was black
and the choice of the interior leather
lining i know from
very very good experience this is your
most basic standard leather strap that
you can buy off the shelf
and it wears pretty quickly yes it will
be a premium version of that
but they have had no real thought no
real
passion about the strap itself which is
kind of very important in a watch that
you're paying 650 dollars for
i know you're paying it for the hardware
and the actual watch itself
but the leather strap should have some
character to it it would have been
really nice if the bottom of the strap
was cut at a unique angle
or something a little bit different the
pointed angle is
very generic it's the again the first
thing you pick when you go to a watch
manufacturer
and the loops i know they're leather
again but it would have potentially been
nice to see a little bit of a metal
addition here just to give it more of a
premium feel
so what about the apple watch five i do
like the fact that they've tried to
create a unique strap something
different even though it's too sporty
for me
i do think that it is different it's
unique and they've actually put some
design and idea
and philosophy behind it again it has
this red
little thread on the side bezel which
i don't know why everybody's going for
it i do like the clean
black bezel with the space gray edition
where it matches the front
display but unfortunately when you go to
the silver or the gold version
it doesn't really tie in too well and it
becomes kind of a bit of a sore thumb on
the design
i think the pebble design is starting to
get a little bit outdated i know it's
very very very iconic to the
apple smartwatch nowadays but i think
when you think about
this design you start thinking ah that's
10 years ago there's nothing new about
it there's nothing really striking about
it so i think the series six
would be nice if it created something
very different maybe an ultra
minimalistic thin
slab i don't know i don't work for apple
so i can't really give you any inside
advice there anyway from an aesthetics
point of view i do
think that the samsung watch 3 gives you
the generic
watch look if that's what you're looking
for whereas the apple series 5 it gives
you that nice futuristic technology look
anyway guys that's all from me today i
hope you enjoyed the video if you did
make sure you smash that subscribe
button 2020 style
give that like button a big thumbs up
make it turn blue because apparently
it does huge things for the algorithm
based on my last couple of videos
it is absolutely true so i would truly
appreciate it if you did
and i will see you next monday